تحالف المعارضه الذي التف حولك رغم
خلافاته الكبيره معه وجد نفسه في جوله
الانتخابات الرئاسيه الاولى خاسرا
للاغلبيه البرلمانيه وقاب قوسين من خساره
الرئاسه مع هذه الخسائر غير المتوقعه فقد
تحالفه حمسته واصيب في مقتل فعلى كمال
كالجدار اوغلو وتحالفه ان يستدرك فارق
الخمسه في المئه من الاصوات كلش دار اوغلو
حازه
44.9% من اصوات الناخبين في الجوله الاولى
بواقع اكثر من 24 مليون ناخب لكن الفارق
بينه وبين اردوغان كان قرابه المليوني صوت
لكن ما شكل عنصرا مفاجئا هو تقدمه كلجدار
اوغلو على اردوغان في كبرى المدن التركيه
اهمها اسطنبول والعاصمه انقره وازمير
وديار بكر واضنه ومرسين وانطاليا وفي
المدن والمناطق الساحليه عامه على بحري
ايجا المتوسط في مدينه انقره رجحت كفه
الارقام لكل جدار اوغلو فتفوق فيها باكثر
من 47% اما في اسطنبول المدينه الحاسمه
فكانت حظوظه ايضا اكبر من غريمه بواقع
48.6% من الاصوات لكن حظوظه لم تكن بدرجه
نفسها في مناطق الزلزال الذي حاولت
المعارضه استخدامه كورقه للضغط على
اردوغان فكانت النتائج لصالح اردوغان اعلى
بكثير
على نسبه مقاربه لاردوغان ثمانيه واربعون
فاصله واحد بالمئه بفارق 481 صوتا اما في
غازي عنتاب فحاز
34.6% وفي قهرمان مرعش نال
22.2% من الاصوات
مرشح المعارضه كل جدار اوغلو اعتمد في
حملته الانتخابيه على طرح برنامج شامل
ووعود بتحسين النظام الديمقراطي بما في
ذلك العوده الى النظام البرلماني وطرد
اللاجئين وفي جوله الاعاده حرص على تغيير
لهجته الانتخابيه الى لهجه قادره على
استماله الناخبين القوميين وانصاره وكذلك
المترددين لكنه لم ينسى ورقته الرابحه
الاكراد التي عززت حضوره وصوتت لصالحه
خلال مختلف المحطات الانتخابيه واعطته هذه
المره 20% من الاصوات الناخبه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات